leute bevor ich mit diesem video
beginnen möchte ich weil der titel des
videos kein klick bett ist euch um eine
sache bitten und zwar wenn ihr
irgendwann der vergangheit mal ein video
von mir gesehen habt und euch in
irgendeiner form unterhalten gefühlt
habt dann checkt auf jeden fall den
ersten link in der beschreibung ab das
ist mein zweiter kanal oder abonniert
ihn jetzt nehmt euch einfach die zehn
sie konnten jetzt gerade bevor ich
erkläre warum das nötig ist denn
vielleicht gibt es diesen kanal auf dem
wir das hier gerade sehen bald nicht
mehr macht das wirklich leute ich weiß
nicht ob ich bis dato jemals auf einem
kanal zum abonnieren von irgendeinem
kanal aufgerufen habe aber hier geht es
um meinen zwei kanal auf dem dann im
videos kommen können wenn hier keiner
mehr kommen können
deswegen macht es unbedingt leute und
fangen jetzt an mitte mio also ja ich
möchte vorweg schicken dass ich noch
bisschen unter dem eindruck der
ereignisse stehe leute also wenn ihr
wenn ich jetzt ein paar sachen sage
diese video wo ich denke das ist
vielleicht übertrieben oder so dann
liegt es daran dass ich selbst immer
noch ein bisschen schockiert bedeute es
geht darum ich werde dieses video kürzer
halten und ich werde auch nicht um den
heißen brei herumreden leute ich hab
einen strike auf einem kanal bekommen
ich möchte euch erklären was das
bedeutet für mich warum es sehr ernst
ist und wofür ich diesen streit bekommen
habe leute erst mal vorneweg was ist ein
streik und warum ist das zu ernst mit
streiks reguliert youtube einerseits den
schutz von urheberrechten auf youtube
hier also beispielsweise dass leute ihre
rechte am eigenen bild oder an videos
oder hat einfach durchsetzen können
andererseits aber auch die sogenannten
community richterin da geht es darum
dass man zum beispiel hier keinen kein
hass im internet verbreiten darf oder
nicht ganz falsche titel oder sowas
verwendet sondern die allgemeine regel
ist nach 3 strikes ist ein kanal
endgültig weg weg frei war und dann kann
man den nicht wiederherstellen erleidet
jetzt habe ich ein star auf dem kanal
und ich bin eben deswegen so schockiert
weil das jetzt quasi ein schritt in
diese richtung von einfach kanal weg ist
was für mich so eine absolut
unvorstellbarer sache ist einfach bei
youtube kanal auf dem ich seit wie lange
seid 2013 seit 120 traditionelle seit
sieben jahren videos hochladen
das dir einfach weg sein soll das ist
für mich vollkommen unvorstellbar so
weit die erklärung für euch heute damit
auch ihr versteht warum die ganze sache
sehr sehr ernst ist und nehmen keinen
spaß ist auch nicht auf die leichte
schulter zu nehmen ist kommen wir zum
inhalt des trikes in strike habe ich für
einen angeblichen urheberrechtsverstoß
bekommen und zwar geht es darum ein
video was ich vor über drei jahren
hochgeladen haben
da ging es um meine weisheitszahn op
dass wir dies auch meine meister zahn op
wenn das jetzt auf youtube sucht könnte
es nicht mehr finden weil strike eben
auch bedeutet dass das video entfernt
wird von youtube so ich habe wie gesagt
ein video über eine weisheitszahn op
gemacht und im rahmen dieser
weisheitszahn op wurde ich mit lachgas
betäubt unseren sogenannten dämmerschlaf
versetzt dass man nämlich so weg gelöst
ist dass man den schmerz nicht merkt was
ich gemacht habe in diesem video ist ich
habe gesagt leute ich werde jetzt mit
lachgas betäubt werden und das ganze
sieht ungefähr so aus um zu
verdeutlichen wie das ganze ist habe ich
quasi in video zitat eingefügt um zu
sagen leute so sieht es aus so kann man
sich vielleicht den effekt von lachgas
vorstellen und dann habe ich eben in
einem video von vor drei jahren ja für
ein oder zwei sekunden eine videosequenz
eingeblendet um ebenso verdeutlicht was
die effekte sind von einer person die
gerade lachgas konsumiert hat gezeigt
wie sich das auf diese person auswirkt
und wegen diesen zwei sekunden von vor
über drei jahren habe ich jetzt einen
streit bekommen
ja das ist das ist schon scheiße hinter
diesem streik steht natürlich auch eine
person die diesen strike bei youtube
angemeldet hat die in durchgesetzt hat
der video hochgeladen hat indem ich
vermute mal der inhaber des kanals eben
lachgas probiert hat und dann eben an
seinen eigenen körper demontiert hat wie
die auswirkung von achter sind und auf
irgendeine art und weise ist der
vermutlich hat man weisheitszahn op
video gestoßen hat das gesehen und hat
sich gedacht dass er habe mir dafür
einen streik geben möchte ich kann zu
dieser ganzen sache aus meiner
perspektive sagen leute ich hätte das an
der stelle dieser personen glaube ich
nicht gemacht wenn ich an seiner stelle
gewesen wäre weil ich nach der
überzeugung leben leben und leben lassen
leben und leben lassen heißt in dem
kontext für mich dass ich schon oft
gesehen habe dass andere youtube-kanäle
meine inhalte verwendet haben das waren
unter anderem fernsehsender sogar also
insofern sind auf youtube sondern auch
fernsehen einem tatsächlichen fernsehen
also vom millionenpublikum aber auch
andere youtuber hier auf youtube
ich glaube ich kann ich von mir selbst
sagen dass ich nie in der position mal
dass ich gedacht habe dafür will ich
jetzt zum anderen kanal in streik geben
ich war auf jeden fall mal der punkt
dass ich mich darüber geärgert habe mir
gedacht habe was mache ich jetzt damit
aber dann stand für mich immer am ende
der entschluss fest ich möchte nicht
derjenige sein der anderen einfach
schadet aus dem aus prinzip einfach um
ihnen zu schaden der quasi aus der
handlung die dem anderen keinen vorteil
selbst zieht weil es einfach nicht meine
überzeugung
und andererseits weil ich auch findet
das eben damit eine gesellschaft oder
was manchmal funktionieren kann eben man
auch über kleinere fehler von anderen
die hinwegsehen muss soweit meine
überzeugung also habe ich in all den
fällen in denen andere kanäle oder
wieder fernsehen da wird aber meine
inhalte verwendet haben immer davon
abgesehen da irgendwas zu machen und man
kann auch heute noch dazu sagen deutlich
mildere schritte als eine strike
ergreifend der streik ist eigentlich der
drastische schritt den man haben kann
man kann unter anderem im video clayman
ja das wären deutlich milderer schritt
wenn man eben sieht okay da verwendet
ihr mann meine inhalte dann fließen
einem einfach die ganzen einnahmen aus
dem video zeigt das video aber trotzdem
online bleiben und der kanal der das
video hochgeladen hat gerät eben nicht
in dieses drei schritte system bis hin
zur canale schon rein
also ich finde ich solche von der ganzen
situation immer nach wie vor noch
schockiert ich weiß nicht ganz genau was
ich damit machen soll ich werde alles
mögliche tun um einerseits denen die
personen die diesen streik veranlasst
hat davon zu überzeugen dass das
vielleicht nicht die beste methode ist
weil das auch meine ehrliche überzeugung
es wieder bergab meinen standpunkt zu
der ganzen sache schon dargestellt
andererseits will ich euch aber auch mit
diesem video informieren und euch eben
schon mal auf meinen zweikanal
aufmerksam machen für den fall dass doch
irgendwas passieren sollte was sich
keiner wünscht eigentlich ganz wichtig
ist auch leute falls ich das gesagt habe
ich werde natürlich nicht den namen das
ist dieses kanals der magistrat
veröffentlichen ist wie gesagt ein
kleiner kanal der würde der hat auch
seit vier jahren nichts mehr hochgeladen
nicht selbst möchte auf gar keinen fall
dass er irgendwann irgendwie gerettet
wird das ist eine angelegenheit
gewändern zwischen den beiden kanal
haben also zwischen mir und auf die
andere seite der personen die ich noch
nicht kenne ich aber angeschrieben habe
zu klären ist ich hoffe ich habe so weit
nichts vergessen oder nichts ausgelassen
fast für euch noch etwas anders zu
wissen leute wenn irgendwelche fragen
betreffen gerne in den kommentaren und
wie gesagt abonniert unbedingt unbedingt
mein 2 kanal ist das wichtigste was sie
heute machen könnt ich hoffe dass das
alles gut geht und man sich auf eine
persönliche lösung einigen kann leute
ich mal an dieser stelle rausgeschickt
hier einfach vor gestaltungs videophone
abonniert haben einen kanal solange das
noch möglich ist
ja ich bin raus musste